so if that's all of the things that the
keyword this doesn't refer to what is it
that the keyword this will refer to
going back to our example of calling a
function we notice that there's a dot to
the left of this example when you notice
a dot to the left of a function
invocation meaning it was looked up as a
property of an object you can look to
the left of that dot and see what object
it was looked up upon the object that a
function is looked up upon when it's
being invoked that object is what the
keyword this will be bound to I'm giving
you an approximate definition that is
useful to get you out of 90% of
situations because of course it may not
be the case we use a dot to access this
function we may for example use brackets
and of course in this example it's also
the case that that object to the left of
the dot is the very same one that it was
defined originally to be a property of
the fact that it's defined up here is a
coincidence
we could just as easily have called that
same function as a property of a
different object provided it's stored as
a method of that second object as well
in any case it's not true that the
object you find a given function stored
within will be what the keyword this
refers to nor is it the case that an
object a function was originally defined
within is going to be what the keyword
this refers to in fact it has everything
to do with that call time dot and the
object that we find to the left of it